10 10. need back up now
he may be outside of his jurisdiction
but that ain't gonna stop old robo from
being tough on crime you are under
arrest dirtbag i mean this dude is
legend
part man part machine
all kind you have the right to remain
silent and you have the right to bugger
off
this is one police officer who doesn't
need a partner
there hasn't been a crook yet who could
outrun the arm
honestly the thugs around here ought to
throw up their hands and surrender to
robocop right now because dead are alive
you are coming with me
no
i must go
somewhere there is a crime happening
[Applause]
you are wanted dead or alive
[Music]
haven't we done this before i have no
record of a previous encounter we have
met
i am sure
fight
get over here
uh
[Music]
finished
[Applause]
you are coming with me
[Music]
tintin need backup now
you are a machine
i identify as human then you choose
termination
fight
oh
true
get over here
oh
fatality
so
[Music]
crime does not pay
ocp built me
to serve the public trust
protect the innocent
and uphold the law
so when i found kano dealing arms to old
detroit's gangs
i had one duty
apprehend him
i never thought the chase would take me
to a different universe
let alone end in a fight with kano's
protector cronica
[Music]
and when cronica went down
something unexpected happened
her power washed over me
sweeping away the limits my designers
had put on my programming
for the first time i saw the depth of
ocp's corruption
it wasn't just a couple of greedy
executives
it was the whole damned company
ocp is making her kill it playing both
sides
selling to cops and criminals
when i get home i am bringing them to
justice
it will not be fast or easy
ocp has too much cash and too much
firepower for me to clean things up
alone
it is a good thing this will be an
inter-agency effort
welcome
to the future of law enforcement